clyde hertzman who is an epidemiologist
in other words somebody who studies
the incidence of health and illness in
large populations
and he's also a physician and he's going
to make the case
that you are something about the
relationship between the genes you were
born with
and the environment with which your
genes have interacted so you are the
product of that interaction
please welcome clyde hertzman who will
answer tonight's question
who are you by arguing that you
are what your genes experience clyde
so the title of my talk is you are what
your genes experience
when many people hear this they think oh
my goodness here's another one of these
genetic determinists who's going to say
that it's all the secrets of who we are
locked up in our dna and it just sort of
lives through
us and i'm not here to say that at all
in fact the new
discoveries that have occurred over the
last half a dozen years or so
are showing us the degree to which our
genes do not
operate on their own but that we are in
a constant interplay between
our genes and our environment and that
the environment can change the way in
which the genes function
my basic idea that i'm here to put
forward is that we understand
now an awful lot more about how
our dna works than we ever understood
before
and what we've come to understand now is
that
our dna our genes are not some sort of a
blueprint
which then go on to print us out as
people and to simply determine what our
lives are going to look like instead the
dna
is in conversation with the environments
where we grow up live and learn
and out of that conversation back and
forth come a number of emergent
properties and some of these emergent
properties
such as our cognitive development and
our social and emotional development
are basic capacities that go on
to shape the opportunity to create an
identity
of the sort that we're here to think
about tonight
this slide here shows you southern
ontario
divided into a number of
neighborhood areas what it shows
is that from the least
vulnerable to the most vulnerable
neighborhood across southern ontario
there is literally a 17-fold difference
in the fraction of children who are
behind where we'd like them to be
on their language and cognitive or their
social and emotional or their physical
development
by the time they reach school age now
the reason that this
occurs early on in life has got to do
with the fact
that there is a very dense network of
sensitive periods in brain and
biological development early on
and as i'm speaking a number of these
competencies are being laid out on this
graph
where the gray part of the graph divides
into the lighter
whitish color at the transition to
school age and so what you can see is
starting at age zero going up towards
the beginning of school
there's a dense network of competencies
that are emerging
in early life when we say that there are
sensitive periods
in brain and biological development what
we're saying is these are periods
where exuberant growth occurs in brain
cell to brain cell connections
as a result largely of the quality of
environmental experience
that you get during that period of time
so sensitivity
means sensitivity to the environments in
which you grow up live and learn
and so when you look at what's going on
with the visual systems
one of the key things that's happening
at that time is that the child
who has a consistent set
of adults up close at their focal length
within 13 inches have a chance to
develop the visual substrates for
imprinting and understanding
that human beings are themselves another
to understand
that we are the same species as the
people around us
and to start to emotionally decode what
a smile means and what a frown means and
as you can imagine
understanding where you stand in the
social world
and being able to conceive of yourself
as a human being is fundamental to
identity
language has a sensitive period
throughout the early years and in this
period of time
children's development of receptive
language what they understand
an expressive language what they can say
goes up
pretty much as a straight dose response
with the number of words and the variety
of words
that are spoken directly to them per
unit time
so that over the first five years of
life across north america we have a 30
million word gap
which is to say that the child has had
the most language spoken
to them in the first five years of their
life have had accumulation of 30 million
more words
spoken to them than the child who's
heard the least and with that difference
goes the ability to understand and to
express and with the ability to
understand and express
goes the capacity to form concepts of
the self
and others and then finally by age three
and four what's starting to happen is
early experience is starting to shape
our executive functions
in other words what we focus on how we
interpret it how we make decisions and
so forth
such that children who have grown up in
chaotic
threatening unpredictable environments
tend to develop
executive function system that are hyper
aroused but have difficulty with focused
attention
whereas children who grow up in
environments which are
calmer and more predictable and safer
have an easier time mounting a focused
attention response
and what that means is that they have an
easier time
developing in a knowledge-oriented world
a world which asks us to engage in
focused attention
uh sorts of tasks and so by the time
kids reach school age
a whole series of things have occurred
which are either capacities
or incapacities that are boundary
conditions for developing
an identity in our society what happens
in the early years continues to
influence things irrespective of
experience
that comes thereafter it doesn't mean
that what happens in the early years is
the only thing that matters i'm not here
to say
that identities are formed by age five
and that
nothing else can matter but i am here to
say that we have direct evidence that
these
early developmental competencies the
social emotional the language and
cognitive
and the physical have an enduring
influence and therefore
have ought to have an enduring influence
on our identities as well
we have evidence not so much from
questions of identity formation but from
other areas
that show the ways in which these things
persist
throughout the life course and so by the
end of the
um second decade of life things like
school failure
unwanted teenage pregnancy and
criminality
are influenced independently by what has
happened early on in life independent
of the influences that come thereafter
by the third and fourth decades of life
things like obesity elevated blood
pressure and depression
have an independent influence from the
early years other things matter
after the early years but the early
years of that can still be seen
by the fifth and sixth decade of life
you can see the influence of the early
years
on things like heart disease diabetes
and other chronic diseases
and by later in life you can see
premature aging and memory loss
being associated with the early years as
well as things later on and i have a
note to myself
now that i'm approaching the end of the
sixth decade of life to
re-edit this slide
how does it work that early on in life
and at a diminishing but steady rate
thereafter
experience somehow does get under the
skin and change our brains and our
the rest of our biologies in ways that
go on to influence
health well-being learning and behavior
across the life course
and so we talk about the archaeology of
biological embedding because we're
interested in drilling down
to the lowest level that fundamental
level at the dna to understand what's
going on
and understand how all those levels feed
back and so
first then we talk about what i'm going
to call shallow archaeology that is to
say
what's going on at the level of the
whole child and the organ system
and so here what we see is is that at
the level of
shallower archaeology there are a series
of systems that are all
profoundly influenced by the qualities
of the environments that we grow up in
so in fact at the shallow archaeology
level what we have is
in effect an identity system a series
of structures within the brain in
particular that work together
to create the neurobiological conditions
for an identity to occur
and that's very important that that be
in a sense the place where you can see
the strongest impact of the social
environment operating
on the developing human and so this is
one example
and this is an example that can be tied
right back to that original map
because what it's got to do with here is
children from
relatively privileged environments who
were also
in this case in low vulnerability areas
so this would be like those
green areas on the map before and the
others are from lower socioeconomic
environments which in this case
happen to be high vulnerability or the
brown areas and so we've actually gone
out
gotten children from these areas put a
shower cap on their head with 128 leads
and given them a task that requires them
to focus their attention on something
and then watch to see what goes on
inside of their heads the main thing to
notice here is that on the left when you
average over
all of the kids from the green zone
there is a sharp
notch in that black line at the bottom
at 0.3
seconds and on the right hand side you
don't see the same notch
that notch that you see there that's the
focused attention notch
in other words by the time these kids
are in transition to school
we are seeing that their brains function
differently that in fact
the kids who are coming from the
environments of low vulnerability
are able much more easily to mount a
focused attention
response than the kids from the other
side now you might be thinking oh
that sounds like genetic determinism to
me well it's not
you should know that in three months of
of basic a training program that they
developed at the university of oregon
you can produce that notch on the right
hand side
but you have to do it at the right time
epigenetics refers to persistent
and heritable alterations to uh
the dna to our our genes that involve
changes other than actually changing the
gene sequence the way in which
a mutation would so this has got to do
with
things chemical processes metabolic
processes whereby
things sit on top of stretches of dna
and as a result of that can turn those
things
on or off can make them express more or
less
so as you can imagine every person has
one
genome of dna but we can have
many epigenomes based on things being
upregulated and down regulated
now we've always known that that must
happen because
uh early on in gestation
uh brain cells have to become brain
cells and blood cells have to become
blood cells and because they all have
the same dna something has to turn on
and off stretches
but until recently it was thought that
that only happened when organ systems
were differentiating
and then after that it was stable and
now we understand that a large fraction
of our dna maybe as much as a quarter to
a third of it
can remain active throughout our life
courses and and
can be turned on and turned off uh
by experiences that we have
these are two butterflies that come from
sub-saharan africa one of them has a
tendency
to stay in the shade and not do very
much and the other
sort of flits around and is very active
and so forth
so what here you are out on election
night and here's this character telling
you about butterflies
well the so what of this is that until
the genome could be read everybody
thought these were
two completely different butterflies
turns out however they
are the same butterfly genetically
the same the difference is that
one of them was in the cocoon during the
dry season the other was in the cocoon
during the wet season that's it
and look at the difference genes by
themselves are not enough to explain
this remarkable variety so with that in
place then we started to look at this in
humans and we've looked at it
in relation to stress and nutrition and
lifestyle
it's been looked at in relation to
identical twins diverging over their
lifetimes
and we've looked at it in relation to
things like maternal care
one of the things that we've been doing
is looking at people
in middle age who have been followed
since birth so we know their entire life
history
and we can look to see whether or not we
can see what we call
epigenetic marks in other words
systematic changes
in the epigenetic patterns in their dna
gene by gene
according to what their early life
experience was and so
for instance on the 1958 british birth
cohort
in other words these were 17 000
children born in england scotland and
wales
during the first week of march 1958 45
years later when we were able to harvest
fresh white blood cells
we're able to look for the epigenetic
marks of their early experience
and what we see is as many as 1250 genes
express themselves differently according
to the socioeconomic
position that the children were found in
during the first seven years of their
lives that's a full
six percent of the genome expressing
itself differently
as a result of that early experience
the next one has got to do with whether
or not your mother smoked during
pregnancy this is collected
back in 1957 58 when these kids were in
utero and there you can see
nearly 800 genes differentially
expressed
45 years later on as uh following
this difference in exposure and then
finally
based on in this case retrospective
reports of
abuse physical verbal or sexual 1141
genes
differentially affected
in terms of methylation so what's
starting to happen now that we have
these technological capacities
and the forms of interdisciplinary
groups where epidemiologists like myself
and cell biologists of the sort that are
brought together under cpr
programs can work together we can start
to understand
how profound these uh relationships are
and the degree to which early
experiences can land
and can stick on our dna and change the
way they operate
so the final one i'm going to talk about
is something we've been doing recently
and it's very interesting because of the
level of precision
we're starting to get to now we're
talking here about epigenetic marks that
we can see at age 15
in relation to very very finely
calibrated data collection
early on in life and to make a long
story short then what we discovered was
is that
mothers but not fathers stressors
in the first 18 months of life
are showing an epigenetic mark that
persists
well into the second decade of life on
at least 100 different genes
yeah in the preschool period when the
kids are three four and five
it gradually switches over so the
father's stressors
are starting to get under the skin and
influence children's
epigenetic marks more so than the
mothers it's a very very interesting
way that this is played out uh following
the kind of thing that if you wanted to
caricature it you could see
where the caricature would come from so
we're in
early days with this work as you can see
and it's going to take
years if not decades to sort out how all
of these mechanisms go
but what i'm here to leave you with is
the following idea
that basically there is a quality of
identity
that feeds into what irene has spoken
about and what alex was speaking about
which has got to do with an emergent
property of how
genes are basically in conversation with
the environment at all levels
so there is the individual developing
child in the middle middle as you can
imagine
who is surrounded in a certain way by
the family
but these broader environments
are playing into the resources and the
opportunities that are brought to bear
on that child
and those things have the chance of
getting under the skin and influencing
who we are and who we've become thanks
for listening
you